la rentrée c'est aussi parfois synonyme
de petites contrariétés
que ce soit pour les enfants comme pour
les parents comme pour l'entourage c'est
synonyme de changement dans son
quotidien donc on s'est dit tiens on va
essayer de retrouver le bon rythme et
aude lefranc vous allez nous aider pour
ça comment peut-on faire
pas si sûr que c'est toujours une
période avec un petit peu plus de stress
et comme dans toutes les périodes de
transition de changement mais les
petites choses qu'on peut mettre en
place par exemple déjà anticipé une
semaine a valeur avant la rentrée on va
recaler un petit peu les horaires de
toute la famille reprendre les heures de
repas avant c'est un petit peu l'heure
du coucher ou l'art du réveil
le problème c'est que là on est déjà
dans leur rentrée et que ceux qui sont
avec nous et moi le premier je me dis ah
mince j'aurais dû le faire
c'est peut-être un peu tard il ya
d'autres entrées qui arrive il ya plein
de choses aussi qu'on peut encore
anticipé par rapport à toutes les
activités
elle est l'organisation se met en place
un jeu dans les familles aussi que j'ai
autour de moi il ya plein de petites
choses à caler donc c'est beaucoup si
anticipé questionner l'enfant sur les
choses qui vont arriver à bâtir la
semaine prochaine pour faire telle
activité de quoi tu as besoin c'est le
stimuler en fait pour anticiper plus on
va faire cette qu'en fait on va adoucir
les périodes de changement et transition
alors on a compris que pour les chiens
pour les stimuler il y avait la petite
franck est qu'elle est bien un esprit
qu'un tout à l'heure on l'a vu avec la
démonstration pour les enfants voire
pour les parents c'est pas forcément
plus évident qu'est ce que vous nous
conseillez moi j'ai fait un peu parler à
parallèle
qu'on peut mettre en place les petits
rituels dans les périodes de changement
il faut se rassurer faut mettre de la
sécurité mais du coup
donc on peut faire des petits rituels
famille donc ça va être vraiment
cuisiner leur pape préféré des enfants
ou se faire un petit moment à soi une
sortie particulière à faire des choses
qu'on fait souvent depuis qu'ils sont
tout petits et qu'ils appartiennent un
peu kanu et qui vont nous chouchouter
nous rassurer je parlais avec une amie
qui a deux enfants en primaire et qui à
la veille de la rentrée
ce qu'ils font d'habitude jamais ils
sont mis devant la télé ils sont faits
leurs pas et c'était chouchoutage avant
de reprendre
donc il faut adoucir ce changement parce
que voilà c'est un petit peu plus
compliqué mais du coup qu'on mette du
cocon c'est toujours voilà on se mêle on
est un petit peu malmené en a un petit
peu plus stressé donc on fait des choses
tranquille chez soi et ça fait du bien
donc ça veut dire concrètement par
exemple faire ensemble
je sais pour une petite cycliste comment
on peut avoir sur le frigo tiens c'est
je vais faire si je vais faire ça comme
ci comme ça oui ça ça rassure beaucoup
les enfants les petits on va le faire
at-il pas les associer les ados on peut
leur demander plus de le faire l'idée
c'est les aider à s'organiser
ça plaît beaucoup et one up up
voilà il volé vous dit avant j'aurais à
messieurs c'est pour ce faire il est là
oui les one tu es beau tu es beau
continuer au n'offre en effet l'idée
c'est de 6 surtout de les rassurer
anticiper les choses qui vont qui vont
se passer et puis tchéquie ensemble
c'est bon mais les fournitures c'est
fait le nouveau chemin pour aller à
l'école c'est fait c'est utilisé en fait
le média pour assurer l'émotionnel bon
je vais rassurer les web t'inquiète
liwan ton papa il est là tu vas aller le
retrouver mais d'abord journée continue
quand même un tout petit peu à à parler
ensemble à cette de cette rentrée on
cultive des rituels c'est ça oui c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment ça c'est met en
place tout un tas de petites choses
c'est souvent très simples dans le
quotidien qui vont faire que les geckos
qu'on va on va retisser des petites
habitudes qui vont faire du bien bon
vous savez quoi redonner une croquette
aliouane pendant ce temps là on va
donner la priorité aux enfants cet
ancien rituel on est allé avec la caméra
assister aux premiers jours de leur
rentrée scolaire
à nos petits bourguignons et oaktree
franc comtois et ça donne quelques
traits ça vous regarde et et puis nous
revenons ensemble en direct très bien et
est très facile quand j'étais trop
contente parce que ça faisait beaucoup
d'amis je n'étais pas avec ma copine et
du coup voilà c'était super bien parce
qu'on était dans la même classe c qui
copains
je connais des trucs sur le caillou
raison et lui a fait la pause on a créé
du français savaient à lescure et plus
et ben il nous a expliqué comment ça
fonctionnait la classe
l'application en fait pour les devoirs
quand on est malade tout ça
maintenant jouer les
cliquez sur votre et plus inscrits moi
je voulais continuer d'être en vacances
c'était pas possible ils sont adorables
un conte expliquer aux le franc a un
enfant par exemple que les vacances ne
dure pas toute l'année alors aux chiens
d'envoyer sur la confiance assure m je
vais vous le donner mais pour l'enfant
comment fait-on c'est un petit peu comme
pour nous et pillé anticipé ça avec
l'enfant c'est vraiment le préparer pour
sa vie pour sa vie future
c'est vraiment lui faire comprendre
qu'il ya un temps pour chaque chose et
que ben comme nous en tant qu'adulte à
hambourg trôner au travail les enfants
c'est le moment d'y retourner
donc ce qui permet ça c'est vraiment de
le faire anticipées je me répète un
petit peu mais c'est vraiment le
questionner sur toutes les choses pour
l'aider parce que l'enfant ait pas
encore équipés au niveau de ses
capacités cérébrales à à penser le temps
comme nous nous on se balade facilement
qu'est ce qu'on va faire la semaine
prochaine qu'est ce qu'on va faire dans
un an un enfant il vit beaucoup plus
dans le présent si on se rappelle
l'enfant qu'on était elle est rentrée
qu'on avait d'un coup de klaxon étaient
précipités dans la rentrée et on pensait
pas forcément toutes les choses qui
allait arriver donc le rôle du parent ça
va être beaucoup de stimuler sur qu'est
ce qui va se passer ensuite
mais le questionner l'idée c'est pas lui
dire ce qui va se passer c'est à ton
avis qu'est ce qu'on va faire qu'on va
faire telle chose
quelle activité qui veut faire comment
est ce que tu as envie de voir tant
rentrée comment ce que tu as envie que
ça se passe c'est quoi le plus important
pour toi est ce que c'est de faire des
nouveaux copains est-ce que c'est parler
un petit peu plus à l'oral si les
timides est-ce que c'est chanté par ex